bonsoir et bienvenue un savourgarde
spécial forcément consacré à la crise
politique qui s'est ouverte avec le
rejet de la loi immigration hier soir
avec un grand témoin Olivier fort
bonsoir premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste Emmanuel Macron vous accuse
vous et votre parti d'avoir fait le jeu
du pire vous lui répondrez dans un tout
petit instant SEP députés et SEP
sénateur pour tenter de trouver un
compromis sur cette loi immigration mais
est-ce seulement possible la convocation
d'une commission mixte paritaire c'est
donc le choix que fait le gouvernement
pour sortir de l'impasse sur quoi
peut-elle aboutir le texte sera-t-il
forcément durci et puis au-delà est-ce
la fin du et en même temps d'Emmanuel
Macron nous en débattons dans un tout
petit instant sur ce plateau avec mes
invités enfin on ira voir Léa Falco
notre écologiste dans Ça vous regarde ce
so ce soir pour un point complet sur les
conclusions de la COP à Dubaï c'est la
douche froide pour les défenseurs du
climat ce sera à la fin de cette
émission voilà pour le menu Olivier fort
vous me suivez je vous suis aveca ça
vous regarde top
[Musique]
générique d'accord hop là le débat va
donc se poursuivre sur l'immigration
mais à quel prix au terme d'une nouvelle
journée très mouvement électrique même
on va le voir à l'Assemblée on va tenter
de comprendre ce qui peut se passer
maintenant après le rejet surprise de la
loi immigration cette loi a-t-elle
seulement encore une chance d'entrer en
vigueur et au-delà quelle conséquence à
ce qu'il convient d'appeler une crise
politique bonsoir Benoît mournet merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
renaissance des Hautes Pyrénées
porte-parole du groupe macroniste à
l'Assemblée vous débatter ce soir avec
Laurent jacobelli bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous député rassemblement
national de Mosel bonsoir Bir rapal Chen
berger bienvenue député les républicains
du orin enfin bonsoir les AM d'ingava
merci de m'accompagner je vous analyste
LCP bien sûr pour décrypter ce qui va se
passer dans les prochains jours Olivier
fort vous êtes évidemment complètement
parti prenante dans ce débat on remonte
d'abord le fil de la journée pour
commencer les décisions les réactions
soyons clair c'est avec Valérie
Brochard et je suis ravi de vous accill
ma chère valérieons je vous invite à
vous retourner bonsoir Valérie alors
cataclysme on le dit et on le redit hier
à l'Assemblée le texte immigration est
tombé suite à l'adoption de cette motion
de rejet préalable et depuis ce matin on
ne parle que de ça la gifle la claque le
camoufl et ensuite et la suite la suite
mais RIAM mais bien c'est le président
de la République en personne qui l'a
décidé ce matin non sans une certaine
colère Emmanuel Macron a dénoncé le
cynisme et le jeu du pire des
oppositions qui veulent bloquer le pays
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'hier hein
pour faire passer cette motion de rejet
préalable on a vu les écologistes voter
au côté des insoumis voter au côté des
républicains eu même votant au côté du
rassemblement national un méli mélo très
original que le gouvernement n'a pas
manqué de condamner cet après-midi
pendant la séance des questions
gouvernement je vous laisse apprécier
les réponses d'Élisabeth borne à la chef
des insoumis et la réponse de géralde
Darmanin au rassemblement national hier
une fois de plus vous vous êtes coalisé
avec le rassemblement
national
hier hier une fois de plus vous avez
fait le choix délibéré de la
compromission avec l'extrême droite
madame Jaz s'il y a bien eu en même
temps c'est en même temps entre le vote
du rassemblement national et celui de
l'anupes
ils sont en colère ils sont en colère
les ministres et après la Colère vient
le marchandage ce sont les étapes du
deuil en psychologie alors il faut faire
le deuil hein du débat parlementaire
alors maintenant vient le temps de la
CMP la commission mixte paritaire c'est
la solution choisie par le Président de
la République SEP députés et SEP
sénateurs on va le voir vont donc se
réunir à huit clos pour tenter de
trouver un accord ils sont sélectionnés
dans chaque groupe politique en fonction
de leur importance voilà vous les
découvrez ici pour les députés il y aura
donc trois élus du groupe Renaissance un
élu RN un élu LFI un élu LR et un élu
démocrate du côté des sénateurs toujours
en fonction des équilibres de la chambre
haute il y aura trois LR deux
socialistes un siège pour le groupe
Renaissance et un pour les centristes
bah voilà ça fait 14 14 personnes soit
une bien belle équipe de rugby alors on
imagine une grosse mêlée tout le monde
va discuter tout va rentrer dans l'ordre
le gouvernement dédramatise tout va bien
rien de plus normal qu'une CNP ça n'a
rien d'extraordinaire je le dis ici
puisque une très grande partie des
textes qui ont été présentés par le
gouvernement depuis le début de ce
quinena et tout au long du quinena
précédent ont donné lieu à une
commission mixte paritaire conclusive al
attendez attendez on va compter on va
compter ensemble 1 2 3 4 oui c'est ça ça
fait qu élus les républicains alors sur
14 parlementaires ça ne fait pas une
majorité absolue d'accord mais ça fait
quand même du poids par rapport aux
autres groupes politiques et ils vont
peser ces élus les républiain pour que
les discussions et pour que la mêlé
pousse le texte vers une version qui
ressemblera le plus possible à celle du
Sénat beaucoup plus dur sans ame vous le
savez avec un encadrement beaucoup plus
ferme concernant les régularisations de
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension et ça ça c'est une
formule qui réjouit Éric cioti nous
avons toujours dit que nous défendrons
jusqu'au bout le texte du Sénat tout le
texte du Sénat rien que le texte du
Sénat bien joué bien joué pour leslr
retour à un texte beaucoup plus dur et
au passage un joli taquet he pour le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui reste à
leurs yeux et bien le traître absolu
alors le choix de la CMP donc la
commission mixte paritaire Valérie
est-ce que ça résout la crise politique
ou pas forcément ah pas vraiment c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire Myriam
admettons que les 14 parlementaires se
mettent d'accord sur un texte on dit
alors que la CMP et conclusive bien mais
pour être adopté ce texte devra donc
repasser par les deux chambres sans
débat mais avec un vote à chaque fois
pour son passage au Sénat si la version
de droite s'impose pas de souci mais
quand il reviendra ici même à
l'Assemblée Myriam que va-t-il se passer
après la colère et le marchandage
viendra peut-être l'acceptation mais
l'acceptation de quoi et bien je vous
laisse en débattre avec vos invités
merci beaucoup merci Valérie Brochard
c'était très clair pour une première
Benoît mournais je commence avec vous
vous deviez élargir rappelez-vous pas
rétrécir et et donc c'est un échec
absolu he c'est pas mon mot c'est celui
de Gérald d'armanin qu'est-ce que vous
avez raté c'est le temps de
l'introspection aussi ce moment-là
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché oui bonsoir
incontestablement nous sommes pas dans
la situation que nous souhaitions mais
ce à quoi nous avons assisté hier c'est
quand même assez invraisemblable
c'est-à-dire une coalition des
contraires alors vous répondez pas à ma
questionir le débatce que vous regrettez
personnellement qu'est-ce qui n' pas
marché group de la majorité plus
l'éliotte nous sommes en majorité
relative que vous vous on sera jamais en
majorité absolue la mission était
impossible alors si vous me dites
qu'est-ce que je regrette à titre
personnel fallait-il commencer par le
Sénat c'est une question légitime
puisque en effet le texte a été quand
même décalé sur la droite si on dit ça
rapidement et ensuite ça a permis pardon
orn et OLR de se planquer désormais pour
esquiver le débat c'est quand même
extrêmement paradoxal que des thèmes que
vous vous énoncez être vos vos thèmes de
prédilection hm
hm tout le monde se renvoie la balle ce
soir mais c'est intéressant de
d'entendre chaque groupe déjà position
ça fait des mois qu'on négocie en
coulisse ce texte ici à l'Assemblée il a
été déjà adopté au Sénat au fond vous
avez dit peut-être pas passer par le
scénat au début mais qu'est-ce c'est
comment vous l'expliquez cet échec mais
non mais si vousz uniquement parce que
il y a unealition cont dis non il faut
toujours se remettre en question vous
avez raison on est en majorité relative
donc ça c'est une donnée une donnée
d'entrée ensuite ce qui est quand même
assez paradoxal c'est qu'on a des
groupes de laanupes qui pensent
strictement le contraire du du RN et de
LR sur ce sujet des du contrôle des flux
migratoires qui viennent se coaliser
pour empêcher le débat il s'agissait pas
hier du vote final sur le texte je
rappelle que le texte avait été
travaillé et voté en commission des lois
avec le Grou tout le mond a bien suivi
est-ce que c'est pas le signe que les le
en même temps migratoire régularisé d'un
côté fermeté sur les expulsions de
l'autrees ça n'est pas possible je crois
exactement le contraire si vous voulez
ce texte il est bâti sur deux jambes il
est bâti sur la jambe de fermeté pour
pouvoir mieux éloigner les étrangers
délinquant mais aussi pouvoir mieux
intégrer par la langue et par le travail
et une chose dont on a le moins parlé
dans ce texte qui est probablement le
plus important c'est la simplification
de l'office du juge aujourd'hui le
contentieux administratif est embolisé
un contentieux sur deux par le droit des
étrangers on a 13 procédur on met 3 ans
aux gens pour pour répondre aux
personnes ce qui est pas humain on veut
dans ce texte revenir à trois procédures
et répondre dans mais le débat a tourné
court et il n'y a pas ces de semaines à
l'assemblé donc c'est très regrettable
et pour la nuupes quand même je veux
dire delphine batoau a été extrêmement
courageuse il y a un grand cynisme alors
rappelez parce que dphine bateau elle n
pas voté travailleurs en défendant les
travailleurs l'intégration des
travailleurs immigrés et bien renoncer à
ça pour finalement revenir à un texte du
Sénat qui le prévoit absolument pas
alors Olivier fort on les entend ces
mots depuis ce matin cynisme langage
cynisme vous faites le jeu du pire c'est
ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron dans le H cl
du Conseil des ministres aujourd'hui
vous faites le jeu du pire en vot temp
avec le rassemblement national qu'est-ce
que vous répondez bon que tout ça est
complètement dérisoire la réalité c'est
que nous sommes opposé à ce texte nous
avons les écologistes qui défendent une
motion de rejet vous ne voulez quand
même pas que nous votions contre nos
convictions et que nous adoptions en
fait un texte que nous refusons donc on
nous propose le rejet nous rejetons
c'est à peu près logique jusqu'ici non
et donc je vois qu'il y a des gens qui
s'indignent quand les gens tiennent leur
conviction évidment pour eux c'est
compliqué pourquoi parce que ils ont une
vérité par assemblée vous avez en fait
les amis de monsieurs qui au Sénat ont
voté le texte de la droite et qui à
l'Assemblée nous disent oh c'est affreux
mais quelle est la ligne de ce
gouvernement quelle est en fait sa
vérité quel texte à quel texte ve
veul-il aboutir moi je vois que en
faital renaissance des convictions à
géométrie variable très variable puisque
même sur laame il a au Sénat laissé
passer pu puisqu'il a dit je laisse ça à
la sagesse du Sénat le Sénat a donc
refusé enfin a rejeté laame et même
ensuite à l'issue du vote pour le vote
final sur tout le texte tel qu'il a été
tricoté par la droite sénatoriale et
bien les sénateurs Renaissance l'ont
adopté et donc maintenant ils nous font
un cinéma en nous expliquant que en fait
on serait cynique absolu et cetera la
réalité c'est qu'il n'y a pas de ligne
et qu'il y a en fait une espèce de de
flottement général dans la macronie avec
des gens qui ne savent pas très bien où
ils habitent et qui voudraiit porter le
chapeau à tous les autres simplement que
dans ces cas-là il faut tenir sur des
valeurs fortes nous défendons on va voir
si vous avez bien joué ou pas parce que
vous risquez de vous retrouver avec un
texte encore plus dur en CMP on y vient
dans un instant Raphaël chezen Bercher
c'est vrai que beaucoup de vos électeurs
à droite sont peut-être un peu dans la
confusion ce soir ils se disent c'est
bizarre ils avaient beaucoup de
propositions ils ont déposé beaucoup
d'amendements ils mettaient leurs
conditions et le débat a tourné court
beaucoup en partie de la décision
d'erxotti de finalement voter ce se
rejet qu'est-ce que vous leur dites ce
soir d'abord deux choses une première
sur votre votre question c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on va rediscuter sur la
base du texte du Sénat qui comprend
toutes nos propositions toutes les
propositions que toutes les propositions
que nous avions à formuler à défendre
aujourd'hui c'est la base des
discussions pour la suite donc pour nous
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
ce sont nos propositions qui vont à
nouveau être discuté donc évidemment le
débat n'a pas eu lieu à l'Assemblée
nationale il faut bien comprendre aussi
que on a vu comment ça s'est passé en en
commission c'est un des sujets si ce
gouvernement si ce gouvernement qui n'a
pas la majorité et c'est et c'est ce que
ce sur quoi je veux insister ce soir qui
n'a pas la majorité depuis un an et demi
veut construire des majorités texes par
texte il faut qu'il choisisse et sur des
sujets de société sur des sujets aussi
stratégiques que celui-là le soutien sur
des textes des républicains il est pas
impossible mais il est aux conditions
des républicains et il est pas sur un
jeu d'équilibriste qui ne nous convient
pas dans vous auriez eu un texte
uniquement sur la partie fermeté
expulsion vous l'auriez voté écélchir
Laé question sur la question du texte
juste un instant sur la question de quel
texte nous ça fait des mois qu'on a posé
ce que nous demandons c'est à minima le
texte du Sénat on a posé la nécessité
d'une réforme constitutionnelle et d'un
certain nombre d'autres mesures depuis
avant l'été il y a aucune surprise dans
notre position aucune ce qui est la
surprise ce qui est la surprise c'est la
démonstration que nous avons fait notre
capacité à serrer les rangs qui n'avait
certes cas depu et sur laquelle et sur
laquelle ce gouvernement n'avait plus
parié au contraire le gouvernement et
Gérald darana en premier avaient insisté
sur le fait que les députés les
républiicains étaient incapables de
s'unir la principale surprise la
principale démonstration que nous avons
faite c'est que nous sommes capables de
nous unir vous l'assumez Laurent
jacobelli cette union sacrée au fond he
tous contre Renaissance que tous contre
la macronie bah
si il n'y a absolument aucune union
simplement à vouloir faire un texte en
même temps en même temps l'xiste avec
des régularisations à tour de bras et en
même temps soi-disant ferme et bien on a
face à soi tout le monde qui vote en
même temps la même motion de rejet et
c'est assez logique finalement ce qu'on
vient d'entendre ce soir de la part de
notre collègue montre bien que ce P
rejet ne pouvait pas aboutir il nous
explique finalement que c'est le vote de
la honte que c'est une coalition cynique
bref on a l'impression que quand on
n'est pas soumis à la macronie on est
voué au hgémonie de de la démocratie
c'est un peu surprenant d'ailleurs pour
un gouvernement qui utilise le 40 93 en
permanence de condamner ces oppositions
qui soidisant ne voudrait pas quand
Emmanuel Macron toujours dans le hclos
du Conseil des ministres dit au fond il
y a pas d'existence de majorité
alternative et il a raison
RA c'est là que c'est difficile raison
nêes pas prêt vous n'êtes pas prêt à
vous entendre il a raison et c'est pour
ça que nous demandons d'ailleurs une
dissolution parce qu'aujourd'hui avec la
minorité de gouvernement que nous avons
il n'y a aucun consensus possible sur
les grands sujets de société or 80 % des
français penseent qu'il y a un problème
dans la politique migratoire donc il
faut régler cette question soit par le
référendum c'est ce que nous proposons
soit par une dissolution avec une
majoritéésident de la République le
président de la République ne va pas au
bout de la logique il reste dans une
espèce d'entre deux de schizophrénie
politique où il dit à la gauche
aujourd'hui c'est le ministre d'armanin
qui dit à la gauche aujourd'hui mais
vous voyez vous ne pourrez pas avoir la
régularisation vous pourrez pas avoir
plus de souplesse dans les centres de
rétention et il se retourne ensuite à la
droite il dit vous ne pourrez pas avoir
plus de fermeté et bien finalement quand
on ne sait pas où on va on va dans le
mur Olivier fort la réalité du cinisme
elle est en réalité du côté du
gouvernement et du président de la
République la réalité c'est que depuis
18 mois il fait adopter toute une partie
de ses textes avec le soutien du
rassemblement national et ça ne le gêne
absolument pas et vouloir maintenant
nous expliquer qu'il aurait là un
problème particulier parce que nous
aurions voté ensemble cette motion de
rejet enfin quand même ça s'ppelle le
dépement d'écvage vous aussi vous avez
voté des textes du gouvernement je pense
aux à chaque fois à chaque fois que nous
sommes d'accord nous pouvons mais enfin
c'est vrai que sur les textes majeurs
qui s'agit des retraite ou qu'il
s'agisse maintenant de la loi
immigration avant de passer la parole à
monagava pour comprendre ce qui va se
passer en CMP c'est vrai que on se pose
la question de votre erreur stratégique
pourquoi vous avez pas tout simplement
fait de textes ou au moins un premier
texte très clair et là vous aviez on le
voit bien une majorité à droite sur la
partie répression fermeté expulsion et
puis peut-être soit par voie
réglementaire soit par voie législative
un autre texte et là comme ça s'est fait
avec les énergies renouvelables ou sur
le nucléaire vous aviez les voix de la
gauche est-ce que c'est pas un vrai
regret ce soir pour vous alors quand
même si vous permettez sur les 52 textes
définitivement adoptés depuis le début
il y en a eu 49 quand même qui ont été
votés tantôt avec des majorités de
droite ou de gauche vous avez raison le
budget hormi le budget mais
effectivement pour le buete faudra pas
venir faud pas venir expliquer que vous
luttez contre l'inflation normative à la
fin du qu ce sujet de l'immigration
effectivement c'est probablement un des
thèmes qui peut-être
discerne encore un ce qu'on a appelé le
clivage gauche- droite si on pe dire
pourant pour autant ben oui il a
toujours existé et nous justement on est
dans le dépassement on on travaille on
peut avoir des divergences de vue
interne à la majorité ce que je peux
vous dire non ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la majorité est unie hier
d'ailleurs elle l'a montré et que ce
texte c'est pas un texte de combination
politique pour faire des arrangements
avec les uns ou les autres c'est pour
répondre aux besoins des Français à des
solutions utiles la simplification de
office du juge c'est pour ça que le
Conseil d'État a donné un avis favorable
à ce texte il travaillait depuis
2019 c'est je pense quelque chose sur
lequel tout le monde se retrouve passer
de 13 à tro procédures donner les
réponses aux gens plus tôt plus vite
ensuite il y a une réalité de
l'intégration moi je suis député de
lourde on a 800 Ukrainiens je peux vous
dire que permettre de de d'apprendre la
langue et de travailler c'est un
formidable accélérateur d'intégration on
peut pas laisser les gens dans un
nensland juridique dans lequel on ils ne
seront pas raccompagnés alors qu'on a
des besoins de métiers en tention et
vous autre la droit qui défendit les
services à la personne les agriculteurs
le bâtiment de Travaux Public vous irez
parler au chefs d'entreprise qu'
pens trè TR je remarque quand même vous
prenez pas les mêmes exemples que Géral
qui peut-être heuré quand vous dites à
l'opposition si il y a un terroriste qui
passe à l'acte alors qu'il était
expulsable vous l'aurez sur la
confcience est-ce vous reprenez ça aussi
j'allais finir sur ce trè point qui plus
attendu moi j'ai fait une rcontre cityen
su ex frust par que nous avons tous
travaillé des amendements qu'on va pas
pouvoir défendre mais sur ce volet
fermeté effectivement de lever des
réserves d'ordre public pour pouvoir
mieux expulser plus facilement les
étrangers délinquants et bien ça non
mais si c'est ça la réalité et donc
voyez c'est ces trois blocs de solution
dans ce texte et ensuite chacun prend
ses responsabilités de savoir il y a
allez alors ce qui est drôle c'est que
vous avez envie de débattre mais que
vous avez tout fait pour qu'il y ait pas
de débat quand même alle répondez sur le
fond puis ensuite on parle de la c'est
vraiment de la tartuerie et vous mentez
au français aujourd'hui vous pouvez
multiplier à l'envie le nombre de qtf
votre problème il est pas là il est que
vous êtes incapable de les faire
respecter on est aujourd'hui simplement
à 7 % des étrangers qui doivent quitter
le territoire français eu qui eu qui
sont expulsés donc vous expliquez ben
c'est à vous de nous l'expliquer c'est
vous qui êtes au gouvernement donc vous
nous expliquez que ça va régler le
problème il n'y a rien dans cette loi
dans ce projet de loi qui règlerait ce
problème très particulier rien sur les
mineurs isolés rien sur le droit du sol
bref la question de l'immigration vous
la survolz et vous la survolz très loin
la seule chose concrète que vous serez
capable d'appliquer c'est la
régularisation massive de gens qui sont
arrivés illégalement en France qui
travaillent illégalement et à qui vous
donnez une
récp vous auriez pu avoir pendant de
semaines vous nous avez tous plongé dans
un débat de procédure dans un débat de
blocage et dans un débat assez politique
donc on va essayer avec Elam d'Ava de
comprendre ce qui va se passer
maintenant le choix c'est du coup
surprenant qu'on parle de fond et que la
défense soit dire il a des alliances
invraisemblable alors qu'on est sur une
motion de procédure le fait de voter à
plusieurs partis qui n'ont rien à voir
ensemble une motion de procédure ça
n'est rien autre qu'une motion de
procédure absolument et c'est surprenant
que la défense se dire ben vous n'êtes
pas capable de vous m on vote le texte à
la fin Chun chacun a bien pu s'exprimer
sur son sur son positionnement d'hier
Elsa donc le choix qui a été fait c'est
celui de la commission mixte paritaire
c'est un choix assez assez fort aussi un
choix risqué ça veut dire que on
continue le débat continue alors c'était
pas le seul choix qui s'offrait au
gouvernement il y avait la possibilité
de retirer le texte c'est une option qui
a très vite été écartée par l'exécutif
il y avait la possibilité ai de
poursuivre la navette c'estàd que le
texte aurait pu retourner au Sénat qui
aurait dû travailler sur la version du
Sénat ça aurait peut-être paru un petit
peu incongru donc le choix qui a été
fait c'est de convoquer cette commission
mixte paritaire donc on le rappelle
c'est une réunion entre SEP députés sept
sénateurs cette réunion elle est à huit
clos c'est-à-dire que on ne peut pas
savoir ce qui s'y passe à moins d'avoir
des informations à l'intérieur et ce
qu'on sait aussi c'est que c'est une
réunion qui se prépare les négociations
elles commencent bien avant la
commission mixte paritaire on narrive
pas en disant on va voir sur les C on
pas la date encore ni la composition on
n' pas la date encore on sait que ça
pourrait être très prochainement la
majorité envisage avant Noël ça voudrait
dire pourquoi pas en début de semaine
prochaine on a la composition on a les
équilibres et on sait que dans ces
équilibres Valérie Brochard vous l'a dit
la majorité elle n'a pas la majorité
elle doit compter sur la droite
notamment sur la droite sénatoriale et
voilà pourquoi on parle d'un
durcissement du texte si le gouvernement
espère avoir une commission mixte
paritaire qui soit conclusive il faudra
s'entendre avec le Sénat le Sénat et les
sénateur de droite vont demander à ce
qu'on revienou Valée disait quatre
quatre parlementaires LR mais il faut
ajouter le RN là vous êtes quand même
assez assez proche pour durcir davantage
et puis il y a il y a un centriste au
Sénat on sait que le centre c'est pas le
modem he donc c'est plus donc 6 sur 14
ils sont davantage à même de peser c'est
bien ça oui sauf que le rassemblement
national on l'entend bien veut peser
dans la commission mixte paritaire mais
demande plus une dissolution donc est-ce
que le texte du suffisant pour le
rassemblement national on on va leur
poser la question tout de suite qui sera
choisi mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
aussi c'est que même si la CMP trouve un
compromis il faut ensuite que ce
compromis soit voté et on retourne au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée voilà exactement
il y a une option la commission mixte
paritaire elle est conclusive et à ce
moment-l il s'était passé la même chose
au moment des retraites il y a quand
même une validation par un vote des
lectures de ce qu'on appelle des
conclusions de cette commission mixte
paritaire au Sénat comme Valérie le
disait si on se rapproche du texte du
Sénat bon ça devrait pas poser trop de
problème mais à l'Assemblée tout va
dépendre de la copie finale est-ce qu'on
va aller suffisamment à droite pour
convaincre les LR mais est-ce qu'on va
aller trop à droite et dans ce cas une
partie de la majorité bah pourrait
manquer à l'appel au moment du vote
est-ce que ça veut dire que si le vote
est difficile une fois qu'on a trouvé le
compromis j'espère que vous me suivez il
peut y avoir un 493 avant vote il peut y
avoir tout à fait un 493 c'est ce qui
s'était passé pendant l'épisode des
retraites on compte on compte jusqu'au
dernier moment parce que on voit les
équilibres de cette commission mixte
paritaire ça paraît très technique mais
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que c'est
pas parce que un LR un député LR ou un
sénateur LR va dire quelque chose qu'il
sera parfaitement suivi c'est pas parce
que dans la majorité les députés
présents vont être d'accord avec le
texte de compromis que tous les députés
de la majorité Renaissance modem et
horizon vont voter comme un seul homme
donc normalement dans une composition
classique d'assemblée la commission mix
paritaire elle est conclusive tout le
monde la vote là on voit que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et c'est pas
parce qu'elle sera conclusive qu' fin il
n'y aura pas besoin d'un 493 pour le
gouvernement et ben c'est pas gagné beno
Mouret c'est pas facile de se mettre à
votre place parce qu'on se dit le 493
reste une option pour vous après toute
cette crise c'est la grande différence
vous évoquer les retraites qui a été
effectivement difficile c'est que le
texte était très impopulaire là c'est un
texte qui est très attendu au contraire
pour expulser les étrangers délinquants
simplifier les procédures et mieux
intégrés donc ce sera le moment de
vérité le moment du vote dans la CMP il
y a C députés de la majorité je suis
d'accord que c'est pas la majorité
absolue mais à contrario vous êtes
d'accord qu'il n'y aurait pas d'accord à
la CMP sans les députés de la majorité
donc on restera pas sur le texte du
Sénat c'est une évidence d'abord parce
que le texte du Sénat a adopté des
dispositions qui sont juste non
constitutionnelles peut-être que en
passant c'est intéressant
ex sur le droit de la nationalité
quiagtion si qui sont pas en lien avec
le texte vous savez pertinemment on est
sur LCP article 45 de la Constitution
vous pouvez pas amender quand c'est pas
en lien avec TEX cavalier législatif
vous pouvez pas dire que les
dispositions qui sont dedans ne sont pas
constitutionnelles peut-être que le
vecteur est discutable mais les
dispositions en notamment sur l'aide
médicale d'État ça va dans un texte
financier alors
que commion non mais on est sur LCP la
commission la Commission des loi a voté
un texte qui est assez différent du
texte du Sénat vous en convenez donc il
y a des bases de discussion et moi je
suis relativement optimiste pour que
effectivement les se députés se
sénateurs puissent cheminer vers un
texte de compromis qui sera évidemment
pas le texte que les uns et les autres
souhaitent vous savez dans une
négociation le point de sortie c'est
quand tout le monde est mécontent
c'estàdire tout le monde est mécontent
c'est qu'on a trouvé
parfil mais vous voulez un 493 si c'est
nécessaire ou vous l'excluez vous à
titre personnel ben moi je souhaite
évidemment pas que queon arrive là mais
après je pense que le gouvernement sera
prêt à engager sa responsabilité sur un
texte utile pour les Français mais
sincèrement sur ce sujetut texte entre
en viueur sur ce sujet je pense qu'il
est nécessaire que ce texte entre en
vigueur berger il y a ce mot de
compromis il est important ce mot non
mais parce que c'est c'est celui qu'ont
voulu les Français en donnant pas de
majorité absolue au camp présidentiel
donc est-ce que vous êtes prêt à bouger
pour reprendre un terme politique au
sein de cette CMP vous aurez des des LR
présents est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
lâcher pour que arrive un consensus à
l'issu de ce hclos d'abord enfin on a
cette conscience qu'il n'y a plus de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
un groupe principal qui est celui qui
déta termine la composition du
gouvernement mais il est plus
suffisamment fort tout seul ça fait
quand même un an et demi qu'on n pas
trop le sentiment que c'est ça la
réalité de la situation donc oui
Elisabeth borne se tarque d'avoir fait
passer une cinquantaine de textes
regardons dans le détail ce que c'est
que ces textes hein quand on on regarde
dans le détail ce que ça change
réellement dans
le il y il y a il y a du y a du il y a
du chiffre pour faire du chiffre pour
dire on arrive à passer des texte dans
une législature normale on aurait appelé
çaant proposition d'adaptation
législative est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
faire en sorte que ce soit pas
exactement la copie du Sénat comme le
demande Mo ce que je vois ce que je vois
c'est la le satisfacite du ministre de
l'Intérieur à la sortie de la discussion
au Sénat à la sortie de la discussion au
Sénat Gérald d'mananin semblait
satisfait du texte adopté par le sén
donc on a là un très très bon chemin
pour adopter un compromis puisque c'est
un texte qui nous convient et qui
semblait convenir au ministre de
l'Intérieur à la sortie du Sénat donc
pas de conciliation possible rien c'est
le texte à la virgule
prè r ça
s'ppelle ser très utile ça serait très
utile parce que ça permettrait en plus
d'éviter un écueil sur lequel insiste
beaucoup Gérald Darmanin depuis hier
disant on va perdre du temps non si la
CMP est convoqué début de semaine
prochaine avant Noël sur un texte qui
est très très proche de celui du Sénat
on peut avoir voté le
texteob Olivier for après lorobell parce
que je vois bien qu'en fait la
discussion se passe entre vous et chacun
l'aura bien compris en fait vous avez
deux sénateurs PS oui non non mais je
dis pas qu' vous pouvez aussi il se
battront en fait contre le texte en CMP
mais ce que je dis simplement quand je
vois ce plateau je comprends ce qu'il se
passe et comme tous les Français doivent
le comprendre il n'y a de compromis
possible pour Renaissance donc pour le
président de la République qu'avec le
groupe des Républicains il n'y a pas
d'en même temps ça c'est une illusion
total en fait les yeux les yeux de de ce
gouvernement sont braqués sur les LR
depuis un an an et demi et à chaque
étape en fait ils espèrent que les LR
viendront à leur secours sur les
retraites puis maintenant sur la loi
immigration donc arrêtons cette illusion
il n'y a pas de jambe gauche à ce
gouvernement il y a un gouvernement qui
s'est tourné soci comme vous ves des
anciens mais le fait d'être ancien ça
n'est pas une qualité c'est simplement
en fait une trajectoire qui est décrite
donc c'est pas une vertu donc vous avez
des gens qui ont peut-être eu un jour un
une histoire avec la gauche mais qui
l'ont quitté depuis longtemps et donc
vous voyez bien que à chaque étapecun
compromis possible avecu marin de la nup
pour le PS le premier secrétaire mais ce
que je dis moi là devant vous c'est que
le compromis aurait été possible avec la
gauche mais pas sur les bases qui sont
celles qui sont recherché par le
gouvernement le gouvernement ne cherche
en réalité d'accord qu'avec la droite
voir même avec l'ITE sur laquelle
laquelle il fait beaucoup de clinob peux
direot Monsieur Olivier for m'a fait
sourire merci merci c'est déjà ça parce
que clairement si le projet auour
aujourd'hui est dans le mur c'est parce
que à l'Assemblée le gouvernement a
accepté toutes les revendications de la
gauche et que de la gauche ceux qui ont
négocié avec la nupes c'est vous la fin
des mineurs dans les centres de
rétention c'est vous qui l'avez accepté
avec la gauche l'aide médicale d'État
rétabli c'est vous qui l'avez accepté
avec la gauche et donc vous avez
gauchisé le projet en le rendant
inacceptable parce que la politique
d'immigration souffre de trop de gauche
quant à la cmpêtre
trop une négociation à deux niveaux le
gouvernement et la majorité doit
négocier en son sein tout d'abord parce
que Monsieur Sacha oulier qui est le
président de la commission des lois qui
représente la gauche de la gauche de la
gauche de la macronie a posé a posé sur
dans une couverture de journal avec
effectivement l'extrême gauche nupes en
demandant une régularisation massive
allez pas tous en même temps s'il vous
plat je me permet de vous laisser parler
quand par on le sait bien voilà
allez-y président de la commission des
lois a signé une tribune transptis
partisan avec la gauche de la GAE dans
un
journale lauche et donc au final ils
doivent négocier entre eux pour savoir
quel est leur projet apparemment ils ne
le savent pas ensuite ils vont négocier
au sein de la CMP donc 14 personnes vont
décider pour 67 millions de Français de
la politique d'immigration tout cela
n'est pas raisonnable il faut clairement
je crois aller au référendum parce que
sinon il n'y aura pas d'adhésion les
Français n'en peuvent plus de cette
immigration submersive faire de
réérend mais c'est faux il y a débat et
nous nous prenons l'inverse et donc
clairement clairement en tout cas voilà
je vois une belle unité c'estd que quand
je parle il y a il y a apparemment tout
le monde qui essaie de m'empêcher de
parler probablement parce que vous avez
compris parce que probablement vous avez
compris que sur cette question nous
avons raison depuis longtemps et ça vous
embête mais vous êtes un capapable de
négocier on l'a vu monsieur Darmanin
encore aujourd'hui a expliqué à toutes
les oppositions une par une qu'ils
étaient une opposition honteuse et qu'on
ne pouvait pas leur parler ça promet une
alors on a bien compris que maintenant
c'est le référendum la dissolution comme
sorte de condition préalable
quand même que le Président de la
République qui n'est jamais en fait
inattentif à ce que peut réclamer y
compris l'extrême droite a proposé au
rencontrre de Saint-Denis il y a très
peu de temps en fait un référendum sur
la question migratoire parce que il
avait bien en tête d'aller com envis oui
non mais lui a proposé j'ai reçu un
courrier très clair dans lequel il
disait je l'exclus pour les questions
fiscales ça tombe bien c'étit les
questions qui m'intéressaient parce que
moi je voulais un référendum sur les
super profits je l'exclus sur toutes les
questions en fait qui pourrait relever
des textes adoptés y compris par 493
donc ça tombe bien moi je voulais faire
un référendum sur la loi retraite
impossible en revanche il avait ouvert
en grand la porte en disant il sera
possible désormais de faire des
référendums sur
lesex Av des point d'ord on va la
rouvrir elle est fermée par le président
et c'est lui qui décide sur ce point
constitutionnel pas laent jacobelli
commencait à l'évoquer la majorité c'est
vrai est divisée et vous le savez bien
Benoît mournet il y a une réunion de
groupe ce matin je je crois avec la
première ministre et aussi ministre de
l'Intérieur comment ça s'est passé
est-ce que l'unité était au rendez-vous
alors il y avait les trois groupes de la
majorité tous les députés de la majorité
sont d'accord pour dénoncer avec force
l'alliance des contraires ils l'ont fait
en revanche pour ce qui est de la suite
c'est vrai queil y a des subtilités des
nuances voire même certaines divergences
he au sein des trois groupes je vais
vous faire écouter par exemple ce que
pensait ce que voulait faire Laurent
marcogelli président du groupe horizon
ici à l'Assemblée et eran non c'est le
porte-parole du groupe modem regardez
ils sont pas tout à fait sur la même
ligne nous souhaitons dans les délais
les plus brefs qu'une commission mixte
paritaire soit convoquée par le
gouvernement à un moment donné il faut
raison garder prendre le temps analyser
aussi l'échec et ne pas se précipiter
certains veulent aller très vite
d'autres ralentir on retrouve ce débat
au sein du groupe Renaissance c'est
assez simple à analyser ceux qui veulent
aller vite ceux qui veulent un compromis
avec la droite bah c'est la droite ceux
qui sont ceux qui étaient plutôt
favorable avec le texte du Sénat ceux
qui veulent ralentir se poser des
questions montrer aussi les muscles dans
un rapport de force avec la droite c'est
plus l'elle gauche ceux qui sont pour un
retour à un texte équilibré Sacha
Houlier par exemple le président de la
commission oui ou d'ailleurs nos
confrères du site en ligne politico
disait que Sacha oulier présent une
réunion post rejet à l'Élysée hier soir
avait même estimé que si le texte de la
commission mixte paritaire était durci
il perdait d'office 40 à 50 députés
Renaissance autant dire que là il faut
tout recomposer voilà c'est le jeu
d'équilibre combien on gagne drite
combien on perd il a pris grosse claque
ça on l'a bien compris il est toujours
soutenu par la majorité il est soutenu
même si beaucoup disent qu'il ne sera
pas Premier ministre qu'il est très
affaibli que c'est difficile pour un
homme avec beaucoup d'ambition d'avoir
subi un tel revers beaucoup n'étaient
pas étonnés qu'il présente sa démission
par
exemple et beaucoup dans les le la
réflexion qu'il y a autour de cet échec
peut-être qu'il y a eu un pêché
d'orgueil aussi à force de dire à tout
le monde que c'était facile de négocier
que ça s'était bien passé bah finalement
on triébuche un peu à la dernière
seconde alors maintenant on va se poser
la question de la sortie de crise euh
qu'est-ce que vous réclamez vous l'avez
lâché le mot c'est la dissolution
d'ailleurs certain Jordan Bardella et
même prêt à la cohabitation tour de
table juste après le vice-président
c'est ça le président pardonnez-moi du
rassemblement national écouteid vous
accepteriez d'être le premier ministre
d'Emmanuel Macron d'être un premier
ministre de cohabitation bien sûr
si Emmanuel Macron dis sous l'Assemblée
nationale que le rassemblement national
obtient une majorité nous assumerons
notre responsabilité et pour une raison
très simple c'est que nous sommes prêts
non seulement à revenir devant les
Français mais que nous sommes prêts
également à gouverner la France Laurent
jacobelli il est pas un peu présomptueux
là franchement vous avez vraiment
intérêt à à gouverner vous pourvez pas
attendre 207 ça il répond à une question
et oui évidemment la sortie de crise
c'est la dissolution parce qu'il faut
prendre des mesures des mesures
énergiques et des mesures rapide ce
gouvernement n'a pas de majorité pour le
faire des mesures pour l'économie je
vous rappelle qu'on a 3000 milliards de
dettes des mesures pour la sécurité
puisque l'ensauvagement de la société
tout le monde le constate des mesures
sur l'immigration on vient d'en parler
des mesures pour l'emploi et ces mesures
maintenant il y a urgence et donc avec
un gouvernement et une majorité divisé
sans all puisque les LR ne sont plus les
alliés de la majorité et bien il faut
retourner aux ures pour avoir une
nouvelle majorité et dans le cas où
cette majorité serait donné au
rassemblement national bien évidemment
nous accepterions cette responsabilité
qui nous serait confié par les Français
mais on peut pas continuer à avancer
qu'1 k avec des demi-lois des
demi-mesures un gouvernement qui ne
fonctionne pas uni avec une premierre
ministre qui regarde monsieur darmanan
en chien faillance de peur de perdre sa
place des parlementaires qui ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux tout cela n'a plus
aucun sens or la France n'a plus le
temps d'attendre combien de temps ça
peut durer c'est vrai combien de temps
ça peut durer cette assemblée comme ça
un gouvernement vous en déplaise la
majorité n'est pas divisée je sais que
vous aimez bien nous ramener aelle
gauche droite la majorité est unie sur
trois volets la simplification des
procéd dur raccompagner les étrangers
délinquant et mieux intégré à partir de
là on a même
élargi éche complet alors qui ve
territorialiser la liste des métiers en
tension et maintenant nous rentrons dans
la phase finale de la CMP évidemment
nous aurions souhaité on en a bien parlé
simplement vous avez quand même une
force politique qui prochain européenne
est largement en tête qui demande la
dissolution qu'est-ce que vous
rép Premier ministre le Premier ministre
est nommé par le Président de la
République voilà donc les hommes peuvent
se rêver premier ministreoltion rour au
le Premier ministre est issu de la
majorité en général
vousèput à mais c'est une prérogative du
président donc là je veux dire ça c'est
quand même un peu un peu compliqué moi
je pense que aujourd'hui les Français
nous ont pas élu pour qu'on soit en
campagne ils nous ont élu pour agir sur
le réarmement des services publics la
planification écologique le plein emploi
900000 emplois industriels créés 300000
cette année 300 usine on a l'impression
je vais vous dire franchement qu'à part
le rassemblement national tout le monde
a pe de revenir au jamais avoir peur
nous sommes dans l'action vous vous le
souhaitez au
Républicain dire faut jamais avoir peur
de retourner c'est sû on peur de
retourner ça doit être ça doit être la
base quand on fait de la politique on
doit jamais avoir peurcheon voit bien
que l'assemblée est souvent bloqué et
que ce net le sujet ce n'est pasement de
savoir si on va voter dans 5 semaines ou
pas la question c'est que le composition
de l'Assemblée nationale sortie des
urnes il y a un an et demi n'a jamais
été prise en compte par ce pouvoir on a
bricolé là pendant un an et demi on a
fait comme si rien n'avait changé en
2022 en en 2022 les Français ont envoyé
un signal en disant il y a plus de
majorité absolue et les conséquences de
cela n'ont pas été prises en compte on n
pas une crise politique qui a éclaté
hier on a une crise politique qui a un
an et demi et qui n'a pas été traité
vous c'est intéressant parce que vous
dites on nous a pas pris en compte et
cetera il y a eu beaucoup de tentatives
hein des coalition des coalitions avec
LR des accords avec la droite absolument
aucune il y a eu beaucoup de tentatives
rappelez-vous faut in' faut Inn dans les
des cou F ont été passés au républain
pour rentrer au gouvernement vous le
savez non mais attendez on a eu quoi on
a eu des tentatives de débauchage
individuel on a absolument eu aucune
logique de discussion de construction de
convergence de la vision accord de
coalition de gouvernement sur un certain
nombre de réformes avec par exemple un
Gérard larch à matigon est-ce que ça ça
marche pour il pe je je il peut pas y
avoir de coalition on est dans une
situation où où il y a des contraintes
par contre il faut s'entendre sur un
certain nombre de choses mais si ID de
dire c'est on va picorer chez vous quand
ça nous arrange che autres quand ça
nitionand avec un contrat de
gouvernement liste de réform moment à
aucun moment une
disc aucun moment à aucun moment une
telle discussion n' été série si on vous
le proposa écoutez c'est des choses
qu'il faudrait discuter mais aucun
moment c'est intéressant vous êtes prêt
à faire un gouvernement avec la majorité
actuelle je je ne me retrouve en rien
dans cette
majorité n'z pas me faire dire ce que je
ESS de comprendre ce que
vousurobissez Quême y a pas mal de
contradiction à tous les étages dans
tout man vous pose une question j'essaie
de comprendre je dis qu'on a une
situation on a une situation politique
issue des élections législatives que
personne n'a traité depuis un an et demi
Olivier fort on parle aussi on parle de
remanement déjà j'imagine que vous
n'appz pas entrer au gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Maron la réponse est non oui
à la coalition avec la gauche comment ça
peut durer quelle est votre lecture
politique est-ce que est-ce qu' à un
moment donné il faut une conséquence une
traduction politique à ces blocages sur
des textes aussi essentiels mais d'abord
enfin moi je trouve ça extraordinaire qu
on parle de blocage il y a pas de
blocage Vous avez un problème
aujourd'hui qui est qu'il y a pas de
majorité absolue et donc vous l'avez dit
les Français souhaitent qu'il y ait des
accords qui soient trouvés entre les
différentes formations politiques ça
suppose qu'il y ait en fait non pas un
simulacre de négociation mais qu'il y
ait de vraies discussions qui permettent
d'aller d'avancer et de trouver des
accords qui permettent ben de de s'y
retrouver certainement avec personne n'y
retrouvera à 100% de ses petits mais ça
n'est jamais ce qui s'est passé j'ai été
à deux reprise voir le chef de l'État à
l'Élysée j'étis voir Madame borne une
fois à Matignon à chaque fois on a en
fait un simulacre où on nous on est dans
une salle pendant quelques heures
parfois 12h de suite on se parle mais ce
n'est pas un dialogue en fait chacun
parle à son tour parle 20 minutes fin et
la réalité c'est que aucune synthèse
aucune conclusion
aucune capacité à trouver quoi que ce
soit et donc on a en fait un président
qui continue à faire effectivement comme
s'il avait une majorité absolue et qui
nous prend pour desendouilles c'est dit
le mot de la fin qu'est-ce qui se dit en
coulisse au fond ils ont intérêt à ne
rien faire qu'est-ce qui peut qu'est-ce
qui peut se passer il y a un rendez-vous
d'Emmanuel Macron avec les Français en
janvier il y a beaucoup d'échéances qui
font que c'est vrai que le calendrier
est difficile à voir il y a
effectivement les élections européennes
on parle des Joo mais moi c'est plutôt
une question peut-être même si je sais
qu'on a plus forcément le temps mais et
s' ne se passait pas grand chose chose
on l'a vu après les retraites on avait à
peu près le même débat crise blocage et
puis finalement Emmanuel Macron a décidé
de ne pas forcément changer peut-être
qu'il se rappelle aussi que dans les
priorités des Français il y a le pouvoir
d'achat il y a l'accès à la santé c'est
des choses très concrètes c'est pas
forcément des choses comme un projet de
loi immigration comme des réflexions
institutionnelles mais peut-être des
questions du quotidien et peut-être de
dire bah finalement ça va moins changer
qu'on le pense rien changer non sûrement
pas en tout cas on est là pour servir
les Français on est là pour donc là on
pas travaille pas ces 15 prochains jours
je pense ce texte est attendu le
président de la République tend la main
les rencontres de Saint-Denis vous y
avez fait allusion ni le Parti
socialiste ni
les sont donc maintenant que voulez-vous
si vous êtes arrivé si bas dans les
résultats des élections c'est que
peut-être que vous avez perdu les idées
aujourd'hui il y a une tripartition de
la vie politique ça se voit dans les à
tout le monde ça pe vous arriver plus
vite que vous le pensez compris le
in allezieur euré c'était très
intéressant ce débat je pense que les
Français qui nous ont regardé on ont
mieux compris ce qui se jouait à
l'Assemblée merci beaucoup on s'arrête
là merci d'être venu débattre sur LCP
vous restez avec moi Olivier fort dans
une dizaine de minutes il y a un parti
prix ce soir c'est celui de Léa Falco
bonsoir Léa dites-nous au fond ce qui se
profile à la COP de Dubaï c'est le
scénario que tout le monde redoutait et
ben c'est un débat qui presque comme sur
le plateau ne savait pas s'arrêter à
Dubaï c'est la dernière Lig droite mais
on peut commencer à tirer d'ors et déjà
un premier bilan le bilan de la COP
c'est avec vous dansune dizaine de
minutes à tout à l'heure Léa d'abord on
va parler un peu de vous de votre
leadership au sein du PS aussi des des
européennes et puis de ce petit livre
que vous publiez aux Éditions de l'Aube
le capital républicain attaque en règle
contre l'héritocratie proposition
concrète à l'appui regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marion Becker on en
parle tous les deux juste
après si on vous invite Olivier fort
c'est pour savoir si le Parti socialiste
qu'on disait moribon peut reprendre des
couleurs dans cette nouvelle union des
gauches qui se dessine depuis l'acte de
décès de la
nupess il y a un moratoire que nous
avons appuyé sur le bouton pause nous
considérons qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de nous sommes pas dans une situation
qui est nature à faire repartir la nup
dans bonnes condition il n'y a plus de
nupes c'est un constat mais ça n'est pas
mon fait en ces temps électrique avec la
France insoumise Olivier fort tenter de
faire revivre le Parti socialiste la
semaine dernière vous organisiez un
meeting contre le projet de loi
immigration sans jeanluc mélenchon ni
son étatmajor comme pour poser les bases
d'une alternative d'un renouveau sans le
leader des insoumis avec qui vous avez
eu des échanges parfois musclés et
pourtant vous ne coupez pas complètement
les ponts je salue les insommés qui ne
sont pas là je salue Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je salue celles et ceux qui dans ce
combat là partagent tout avec a nous et
vont ensemble défier la droite et
l'extrême droite vous qui êtes député de
SC etmarne patron du groupe à
l'Assemblée entre 2016 et 2018 puis
premier secrétaire du Parti vous faites
entendre votre différence en publiant
votre premire essai le capital
républicain vous y proposez la création
d'une dotation pour lutter contre la
reproduction sociale ou ce que vous
appelé
l'héritocratie Olivier fort vous avez de
nouvelles ambitions pour le Parti
socialiste votre atout les prochaines
élections européennes qui pourrai le
doper car vous présenterez votre propre
liste avec une tête d'affiche médiatique
à Raphaël gluxman dans les derniers
sondages elle devance celle de la France
insoumise Daniel conbendit qui a tourné
le dos à Emmanuel Macron vous appelle à
faire liste commune avec les écologistes
et le Parti radical de gauche pour
dit-il donner un nouveau souffle à la
gauche et rompre avec avec l'humiliation
de la nupè alors on a une question pour
vous Olivier fort allez-vous répondre à
l'appel de Daniel
conbendit réponse Olivier fort bon il y
a des gens qui se sont égarés qui
retrouvent en fait peut-être le sens
commun et qui se disent que finalement
Emmanuel Macron ne pouvait pas incarner
la gauche et c'est très bien qu'il s'en
rende compte il a souvent été
clairvoyant sur l'analyse politique
notamment sur les questions européenes
j'y venais parce qu'il a réussi une
belle campagne on s'en souvient c'est
une option que vous regardez où la porte
est complètement fermée par les verrs
cette fusion des listes poserai la
question au vert vous souhaitez vous je
veux pas ça serait quand même une belle
dynamique ils ont pris une décision que
je respecte et donc je ne veux pas
rentrer dans ce débat là où on passerait
encore 15 jours à se demander liste
commune pas commune et on pass assez de
temps là-dessus donc vous leur posereai
la question et puis à ce moment-là on en
reparlera quels sont vos objectifs pour
ce
scrutin l'objectif c'est de convaincre
le plus grand nombre de Français et
faire entendre une autre voix et rappel
est-ce que c'est aussi ressusciter le PS
ça compte aussi pour le débat à gauche
en 2027 je suis socialiste donc
évidemment je souhaite que le socialiste
soit mieux entendu qu'ils ne le sont
depuis 6 ans mais la réalité c'est que
en fait je souhaite même aller plus loin
je souhaite que la gauche puisse
retrouver en fait des couleurs et
qu'elle puisse même si elle se présente
avec des listes séparé qu'elle puisse se
faire entendre et que nous arrivions à
un total de ses voix qui dépasse celui
de l'extrême droite et qui permett
d'espérer pour les élections
présidentielles et législatives un autre
sort que celui qui nous avvez réservé
tout à l'URE je vous entendu dire
attendez 2027 mais moi je ne veux pas
attendre 2027 et le RN je pense que nous
sommes en
mesure j'ai pas dit que c'était sûr vous
non plus mais nous devons nous au
contraire nous incarner une alternative
et c'est ce que je veux faire avec
d'autres alors certains vous reprochent
encore et toujours de ne pas être assez
clair sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis ses
tweets après le massacre du ramas le 7
octobre on l'entendait encore vous le
saluez vous avez fait ce moratoire sur
l'intergroupe de la nuupes avec les les
mélanchonistes les insoumis
mélanchonistes est-ce qu'il a quand même
franchi une ligne rouge irrémédiable
selon vous éz je ne suis pas d'accord
avec lui mais je déteste la façon dont
il est parfois diabolisé parce que en
fait ça ne correspond à aucune réalité
nous devons être dans une forme d'utopie
conversationnelle en fait où tout le
monde peut émettre dans la discussion un
avis différent d'en différent du l'utre
i conversationnelle à la fin ça peut
être la postvérité je ne pense pas qu'il
so dans la post vérité je pense qu'il
défend une opinion qui n'est pas la
mienne sur le Hamas il a défendu des
positions que je trouve en réalité même
contreproductives parce que s'il avait
accepté de dire que le Hamas était un
groupe terroriste il pourrait
aujourd'hui dire avec nous et avec force
que en réalité si c'est un groupe
terroriste on ne peut pas avoir une
punition collective sur l'ensemble des
habitant de la la population de Gaza
donc ça pas il y a une erreur de départ
il y a un problème effectivement dans
dans leur appréciation de ce qu'est le
Hamas mais je ne veux pas non plus en
faire en fait un groupe qu'il faudrait
diaboliser considérer que parce qu'ils
ont refusé en même temps sur Mélenchon
c'est possible ou pas parce que vous
nous faites du ha en même temps un peu
comme Mac mlch j'assum m désaccord quand
je dis que je suis en désaccord je dis
et je l'ai dit à plusieurs reprises dans
l'année c'est pas la première fois que
je en désaccord avec lui mais je ne veux
pas que on arrive à surjouer les
désaccord parce que la réalité quand
même c'est que dans ce débat sur
israël-pestine il y a beaucoup de gens
qu' faut mettre à amande bien sûr ceux
qui n'ont pas condamné avec suffisamment
de force la et qui n'ont pas qualifié
avec suffisamment de précision ce qui
était le Hamas mais aujourd'hui ce que
vous croyez qu'il y a pas aussi des gens
qui mériteraient en fait qu'on leur
rappelle leur soutien inconditionnel à
un état qui dès le départ a chois pense
BR par exemple et qui donc vous pensez
qu'elle a commis une une faute en disant
inconditionnel sans préciser à
l'existence elle s'est corrigé depuis
non non elle pas elle s'est corrigé
depuis s'est corrigé elle a fait évoluer
son discours mais la réalité c'est que
quand elle est allée elle-même en Israël
et qu'elle a repris à nouveau en fait et
même le président de la République quand
il a voulu une coalition type daesh et
cetera c'est que tous ces gens ont dans
un premier temps complètement collé au
récit qui était celui de l'extrême noite
israélienne n'ont pas pris la distance
suffisante et n'ont pas défendu ce qui
est la position historique de la France
que nous nous avons défendu
depis une position qui permet de
défendre effectivement la paix de Contin
continu à parler aux deux partis au
conflit et de chercher une solution à
deux états pour vous l'union de la
gauche elle est encore possible avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon oui ou non mais euh
je ne veux pas personnaliser je dis que
avec non mais si vous posez la question
de savoir si est-ce que j'ai des amis
parmi les insoumis la réponse ou non
mais ma question elle porte sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais Jean-Luc ça dépendra de
ce de l'attitude qu'il adopte en réalité
il y a beaucoup de sujets sur lesquels
nous sommes en réalité nous pouvons être
d'accord mais c'est son attitude sa
méthode c'est pas oui mais c'est que moi
je veux un rapport égalitaire au sein de
la gauche je ne veux pas que quelqu'un
se pose comme le leader et considère que
à lui tout seul il fixe la ligne ça
c'est pasib
continueette troire la rép est non si en
revanche il est prêt à accep l'idée que
un collectif et bien il faut à chaque
instant en
chercher une alliance c'est très clair
vous l'avez dit c'est très clair
certaines condition je REM la gauche
vous publiez un petit livre aux éditions
de l'Aube sur le capital républicain
pour en finir avec la reproduction
sociale que vous diagnostiquez fort bien
vous proposez un capital financier
accordé à la naissance à tous les jeunes
qui vont au bout d'une formation
supérieure on pense évidemment au
revenus universel de Benoît amamont de
la campagne de 2017 c'est la même chose
pas toutalement non en fait l'idée c'est
que vous avez aujourd'hui des inégalités
qui sont un peu invisibilisé mais si
vous êtes un élève qui s'arrête à 16 ans
l'état la collectivité vous aurait
consacré 135000 € pour vous accompagner
vous enseignant et cetera le chauffage
vos meubles et ça tout ce qui a concouru
à votre éducation jusqu'à 16 ans si vous
avez été jusqu'à bac + 5 c'est 245000 €
donc en réalité on continue aujourd'hui
par le système et c'est c'est comme ça
en fait on favorise et on accompagne
même financièrement davantage ceux qui
réussissent et il se trouve que ceux qui
réussissent sont d'abord les enfants des
catégories les plus aisés et ceux qui
échouent le plus sont ceux des
catégories les plus modestes et donc ce
que je dis c'est que il faudrait que
nous fassions en fait donc à un moment
ce rattrapage et qu'on puisse dire que
l'État la France supe de tous les
enfants de la patrie de la même façon et
qu'elle leur consacre un budget
identique et donc le solde ce qui n'a
pas été consommé pour ceux qui se sont
arrêté prématurément peut être consommé
plus tard et donc vous avez finalement
arrêté vos études très tôt vous êtes
devenu je sais pas j'ai dis n'importe
quoi vous êtes devenu comis boulanger et
puis à 35 ans vous voulez devenir
vidéaste et donc vous vouz êtes
caméraman à LCP il y a une formation je
ne sais pas combien de temps elle dure
un an vous ne pouvez pas vous la payer
bah là avec votre solde vous pouvez vous
la payer et et vous pouvez
réentreprendre une autre carrière
professionnelle changer de trajectoire
et je pense à tous les métiers les plus
pénibles où on a des gens qui à 16 ans
on le dessin qui s'est complètement figé
à 16 ans on vous dit toute votre vie
désormais vous ferez ça bah là moi je
propose d'ouvrir cette possibilité et de
donner une deuxième chance à ceux qui ne
n'ont pas eu au moment de la formation
chaque fois qu'on parle d'un capital
financier ou d'un mode opératoire proche
d'un revenu universel c'est
systématiquement le même obstacle c'est
le coût d'ailleurs vous le chiffrez hein
16 vir9 milliards d'euros par an qui
finance qui paye alors ce que je dis
c'est que en réalité ce capital il n'est
mobilisable c'est pas en fait je veux
pas prendre des vacances au céchelle à
25 ans et donc je mobilise le capital on
a bien compris et tout le monde ne le
prend pas c'estàd que ceux qui ont
faitudes supérieurs n'ont plus c'est
colossal he 16 milliards par an où vous
trouvez l'argent qu'on dit d'abord ce
que je dis c'est que a
priori tout le monde ne déposera pas un
projet chaque année donc on pense que à
8000 milliard par an on est déjà très
au-dessus de ce que pour être la réalité
donc partons de 8 milliards et après où
est-ce qu'on les prend ben on les prend
tout simplement dans la fiscalité de
l'héritage vous avez des gens qui sont
des les libéraux nous disent quoi ils
nous disent que c'est le travail c'est
l'efft qui doit être rémunéré et que
l'héritage et bien en fait est une forme
de paresse et on devrait banir les
héritiers voilà ce que disaient les
libéraux au départ on a l'égalité des
chances et puis après ben en fait c'est
chacun Sonon ses mérites ben voilà
faisons en sorte
que voilà absolument sur les assurances
vie qui sont en réalité on je parle pas
de vous supprimez tous les avantages
fiscaux de de l'éritage mais je dis
simplement que pour les très gros
héritages et pour ceux qui ont des
placements sous forme d'assurance vie
mais qui sont en réalité des placements
qui permettent d'optimiser et bien pour
cela effectivement il faudra leur en
prendre une partie pour pouvoir financer
effectivement le capital républicain
détenir une grande fortune accumulée par
son ascendance ne relève d'aucun autre
mérite que d'être né c'est aussi un un
véritable panflet contre on va dire
l'utopie de la méritocratie ou le myth
de la méritocra aujourdui nous vivons en
éitocratie regardez le nombre de ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui milliardaires et
qui ont en réalité hérité de leur
milliards qui ne sont pour rien mais
vous allez les faire fuir ces fortunes
vous le savez non pourquoi les faire
fuir à l'étranger vous savez que
aujourd'hui en fait quelqu'un qui hérite
d'une très grande fortune et cetera
devrait être taxé à 45 % dans la réalité
à combien sont-ils taxés à 5 % et vous
pensez qu'on peut pas faire mieux pensez
qu'on peut pas leur en prendre un peu
plus pour permettre justement à des
enfant oui enfin c'était pour vous je
voulais pas vous prendre à parti mais je
veux dire que est-ce que vous pensez que
est-ce que les gens pensent qu'on ne
peut pas prendre une are petite partie
pour aider justement ceux qui n'ont pas
eu la chance d'avoir des parents moi
jeha pas décapiter ceux qui ont eu cette
chance là mais aidons aussi ceux qui
n'ont pas eu cette chance et donnonsleur
cette possibilité de retrouver un espoir
et faisons en sorte que tous ces enfants
qu'on a vu parfois basculer dans la
violence et bien se disent que on pense
à eux jusqu'au bout et tout au long de
leur vie très bien merci vous restez
avec moi merci beaucoup Olivier fort le
capital républque c'est aux Éditions de
l'Aube pour un droit universel à
l'avenir je voudrais que vous restiez
avec moi parce que vous allez pouvoir
réagir à la chronique de Léa Falco c'est
l'heure du bilan de la COP 28 dans
Action planète tout de
suite bonsoir cher Léa
bonsoir On vous a laissé du temps ce
soir parce que on s'est interrogé toute
la journée mais y arri-t-il il y a un
accord oui pas d'accord sur quoi sortie
fossile ou pas on commence quoi par les
par les bonnes nouvelles bah allez
commençons par il y a surtout des
mauvaises on les bonnes nouvell alors
bonne nouvelle déjà dès le premier jour
de la COP 28 on a eu cette nouvelle de
la création du fond pertes et dommages
qui avait été acté pendant la dernière
COP mais pas financé ce fondlà il a pour
objectif de financer les destruction lié
aux événements climatiques extrêmes donc
inondation cyclone toutes ces joyeusetés
principalement dans les pays des Sud
parce qu'en plus c'est des pays qui
n'ont pas historiquement contribué au
réchauffement climatique qui n'ont pas
les moyens de prévenir ces changements
là et qui sont assez peu soutenus par la
communauté internationale donc bonne
nouvelle mais le fond il a aujourd'hui
été abondé seulement de 700 millions
d'euros alors ça peut paraître beaucoup
mais les besoins an c'est ent 290 et 580
milliards de dollars effectivement
d'autant plus qu'on a promis 100
milliards qui ne sont toujours pas sur
la tableou les CAES sont resté longtemps
mais il faut voir ce que ça donne sur le
moyen terme les moins bonnes nouvelles à
présent et ben évidemment le fait queon
est toujours pas aujourd'hui à cette
heure-là d'accord la mouture qui a été
proposée hier et qui a été jugée
irrecevable par une partie des des
parties à la à la table c'est le texte
dans lequel la sortie des énergies
fossiles a été éliminée pour parler
plutôt de diminution des énergies
fossiles ça c'est plutôt une explication
de texte qui convient au pays
producteurs de pétrole et à la coalition
carbone en général donc le texte est
toujours en cours de discussion mais il
est assez peu probable à cette heure que
on voit réapparaître la notion de sortie
des énergies fossile et encore moins une
date donc et du coup ça fait part à de
nouveaux discours qui vont arriver sur
la capture et le stockage de carbone qui
vont nous maintenir dans l'inaction
quelques années de plus et puis surtout
ça ne fait pas que des heureux parce que
je cite le ministre des Ressources
naturelles des îles marchalles une un
pays évidemment très vulnérable face au
submersion qui nous dit nous ne sommes
pas venus à la COP pour signer notre
arrèe de mort et nous ne retournerons
pas silencieusement dans notre cimetière
aquatique donc finalement le bilan bah
le bilan c'est qu'une COP bah c'est une
COP donc déjà c'est un exercice
diplomatique qui se réduit souvent
malheureusement au plus petit facteur
commun ça veut pas dire qu'à côté de la
COP on peut pas avoir des actions
multilatérales et c'est un peu ce qui
est en train de se passer euh pour jouer
avec les règle de la COP les petits
États insulaires ont lancé un traité de
non prolifération des énergies fossiles
ils sont à cette heure-là 12 pays à s'y
associer avec en plus le soutien du
Parlement européen et de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé mais si on a on
avait une coalition c'estàdire pas
forcément tous les pays de la COP qui
s'y associaient et qui prenaient des
exigences ambitieuses pour leur
politique nationale on pourrait aller
dans une direction un petit peu plus
intéressante pour savoir tout ça il
faudra se retrouver l'année prochaine à
la COP 29 qui devrait se passer en
Azerbaïdjan donc vous allez ça va vous
dire quelque chose 90 % de l'économie
absolument qui repose sur le pétrole le
gaz et un petit peu de charbon encore
les fossiles Olivier fort elles sont
toujours comme ça c'est C à chaque fois
on mitigé mais là elle était à Dubaï 7e
pays pétrolier de la planète on pouvait
s'attendre à à autre
chose d'abord c'était à Dubaï c'était
avec quelqu'un qui enfin le le président
de la COP lui-même producteur de pétrole
ça était pas parti sous les meilleurs
hospice mais je voulais faire un
parallèle avec le débat que nous avons
eu au tout début de l'émission si
vraiment il y a des gens qui sont
sérieux et qui pensent que il y a un
risque migratoire la question qu'il
devrait traiter c'est pas en fait de
rajouter des normes et cetera c'est de
s'occuper du climat parce que en fait ça
c'est les chiffres qui sont donnés et
qui sont astronomiques en fait d'ici
2050 les projections les plus
pessimistes parlent d'un milliard 2 de
en fait d'habitants de la planète qui
vont bouger alors pas tous venir en
Europe bien sûr d'abord ils vont bouger
dans leur propre pays puis après ils
passeront dans le pays frontalier mais
enfin une partie aussi viendra en Europe
et donc si vous voulez veréritablement
limiter les causes migratoires vous
devez lutter contre le climat et
malheureusement on voit là que c'est la
grande h cris et malheureusement à la
COP je vois les grands discours
d'Emmanuel Macron je vois canag espagier
runchier en rajoute des caisses mais la
réalité c'est que dans la délégation de
la France il y avait six représentants
de Total ennergie total Energie qui est
en train de bâtir en ce moment un projet
entre la Tanzanie et l'Ouganda et qui
est un projet qui il faut mettre à la
table quand même pour sortir des
fossiles les pétroliers forcément C CASL
on soutient pas des projet dont on sait
que pendant 25 ans ils vont être plus
polluant que tout ce que nous pouvons
consommer en France donc en fait il y a
là une une forme de de en même temps qui
est en même temps hypocrite c'estàdire
que on vous nous raconte de belles
choses et en même temps on fait tout le
contraire donc c'est là où effectivement
ça doit s'arrêter et c'est pas la peine
de venir nous dire attention ils vont
venir ils vont nous submerger et cetera
si on ne fait rien sur le climat merci
beaucoup Olivier fort le débat
continuera en coulisse parce qu'on a
plus le temps merci beaucoup Léa Falco
le capital républicain c'est àire aux
éditions de l'au merci de nous avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur LCP à
[Musique]
demain